[Musique]
ah bonjour
voila bonjour à tous je suis
complètement moi je suis dans mes états
déjà merci beaucoup d'être avec moi
merci d'être resté moi je sais ça fait
dix ans j'ai pas été aussi stressée de
présenter un bulletin météo marc et moi
je sens que vous êtes vous êtes
ravissante
alors on va essayer de voir si
mademoiselle ne le cache pas trop là une
partie de la france quel mot désigne une
paire de fesses et des gros pain de
campagne roh
des niches
[Applaudissements]
français avec une petite webcam de paris
des belles dames une grande dame ça
c'est pareil en france
et alors on pourrait voir la carte s'il
vous plaît j'essaye de faire des petits
jeux de mots
le 5
certains la préfère à barreaux
[Musique]
c'est quand même pas ça la réponse
les températures ont honte dit d'aller
vite mais moi je veux en profiter à
dents j'ai envie de rester un peu voire
pas bon les températures
la douceur qui donne du nord-est à la
méditerranée et cet après-midi de la
chaleur comme moi sur le plateau là je
suis complètement avantage les
le trouble isaf
[Musique]
mais trop bizarre les femmes peu trop
bizarre
le 5
certains la préfère apparente la poutre
la poutre apparente la chanteuse
vous avez évidemment compris que quand
on parle de poutres apparentes pour
parle de celle des fermettes normande
bien évidemment vous croyez que l'époque
est au féminisme à l'égalité totale
entre hommes et femmes et pourtant il ya
encore un peu de route sur le chemin de
la libération des femmes neuf femmes sur
dix préfèrent que les hommes fassent le
premier pas 18% trouve qu'une femme qui
drague s'est déplacée on parle de drague
de séduction on a marché sur une célèbre
application de rencontre alors on va des
débuts veut mais la musique a toujours
été là pour nous apaiser puis quand on a
été un peu plus serein on a monté ce
projet
c'est une belle aubaine mauvaise idée
m
[Musique]
alors oui
[Applaudissements]
pour un tout petit incident ne devenez
pas la dame qui prend la situation en
main fait acte d'autorité prétend que
ceci est trop chaud ou trop froid
accablante ainsi son pauvre compagnon
d'un complexe d'infériorité
[Musique]
quand vous touchez plus terre
eric geboers d'air vous en faites la
semi confession quand vous revenez au
tout début du livre sur le sujet de
français vous dire j'étais ivre de moi
même moi j'ai pas l'impression que vous
ayez vraiment dessaoulé depuis inquiétez
pas eric m'a écouté vous parler par
exemple de votre triomphe médiatique à
ses news mon triomphe médiatique assez
news n'arrange pas mes affaires un mx ce
soit un succès je veux bien comprendre
mais laisser aux autres le soin de le
dire ça l'air de rien mais juste ça ça
suffit après les coucougnettes on peut
pas faire grand chose parce que il a
deux couleurs à dire
il est noir et blanc gris et blanc gris
noir et blanc parce que je préfère à
l'écourter je peux dire c'est immense je
vous confirme que je suis atteint d'une
maladie qui s'appelle le vitiligo qui
n'est ni douloureuse ni contagieuse mais
qui est très visible et encore pour moi
elle l'est moins que pour d'autres bon
voila moi j'ai une barbe qui a une drôle
de drôles de couleur c'est comme ça
c'est un triomphe par rapport aux autres
chaînes d'info mais par exemple nagui à
la même heure chaque soir sur france 2
fait trois fois plus d'audience que vous
faîtes fausse de est là depuis 50 ans
vous faites 5% au lycée news une chaîne
de vous quand je sers vous de vous en
êtes pas rendu compte mais les
programmes ont changé depuis le chalet
alors et alors quand je suis arrivé
la tranche horaire faisait 80 mm
réacteurs on est entre 800 mille et un
million tout c'est vrai moi j'appelle ça
un trio l'arc de triomphe est en pleine
mue il va se transformer en paquets
cadeaux géant l'emballage a commencé
aujourd'hui crassat des cordistes qui
vont déployer quelques 25 mille mètres
carrés de tissus euros cyclable sur
selon des plans imaginés par l'artiste
christo décédé en mai 2020 après le pont
neuf ou encore le reich tag en allemagne
c'était son voeu le plus cher que
d'empaqueter le monument parisien mais
ça prouve que manifestement vous ne
connaissez pas bien les chiffres bas
voilée et j'espère qu'en économie vous
serez meilleurs que ça oui bah oui parce
que pardon oui on fait à peu près en ce
moment le même nombre de téléspectateurs
je suis d'accord avec vous sauf que vous
voulez faites 19h en effet vous avez vu
leur entre minuit et 2 heures du matin
c'est incomparable ce qui compte c'est
la part de marché on entend la douleur
on entend la passion on entend des
sentiments tellement pur la grande
l'unique la seule mais me
[Musique]
reconnaît
c'était mylène maladie verse
chante tellement bien et je sais pas non
mais ça fait du bien ça fait aucun
cadeau
burgeat les
jeunes
seraient touchés cette fois je voudrais
une fleur ou une plante
commençant par la lettre j'ai
donc changé faut foncer la tête
jamaïque jasmin je suis mauvaise réponse
c'est fini tu ne veux plus répondre
c'était génial c'est quoi ton nom
jasmine jaspart des jasmins
voilà
l'épisode tandis que m6
mes parents ont pas eu avec
jets les copies des
faits
n'était pas mieux